fortunately I was the main choice of the
guy who wrote the show so his his
opinion tended to trump anyone else's so
I own stream debt of gratitude to mr.
whiner for that and yes I gave myself
until the age of 30 to at least get a
job in the in the professional acting
world I moved out to LA when I was 25
and I figured five years was a pretty
good round number to see what the market
was going to say about my viability as
an as a wage earner in said market and
and I by the time I was there I turned
30 working on a movie actually so I made
it in right under the wire and and it's
been the positive by fits and starts
ever since has it been different than
you imagined it would be yes is the
short answer
and and to extend on that I don't know
what I imagined honestly I certainly
didn't imagine being on on posters and
and and having this kind of celebratory
experience ever I don't know if anybody
really thinks of that when they think of
their of their career I think they that
they just want to have one job that
turns into another job that turns into
another job so this has all been been an
incredible ride and a ride that is now
coming to coming to an end
Don Draper's been on an incredible ride
in Mad Men there is a scene in which Don
Draper your character is presenting a
Kodak color wheel mm-hmm do you remember
that sing can you describe what that was
at the end of season one and it's one of
the first time actually it's it serves
as kind of a nice counterpoint to
actually the pilot of the of the show
where Don presents Lucky Strike and wins
the accountant and at the end of that
season we see Don going in and
presenting to Kodak for their new
slide projector called the carousel and
it's a it's a very emotional pitch and
it's a very sticky brings in the idea of
nostalgia which of course we then
realize over the course of over the
course of the show we've realized that
Don's connection to his past is not
exactly what he says it is so there's a
pretty thick layer of irony as well as a
pretty thick layer of emotion given
given what he does for a living
what's the relationship if any between
Jon Hamm the actor and the character
that you play who has this other
personality and background because Don
Draper is not who he says he writes how
did you get connected with well you can
obviously draw a parallel between you
know actors by nature tend to tend to
put on other persona and roles and
clothes and and act different parts in
their lives so Don is has taken that to
a an extreme level if you want to look
at that look at it that way by necessity
I think I think he did it to to survive
his if you do it to survive I mean when
you were young and your relationship
with having lost your parents I don't
think that that was why I became an
actor I think I became an actor because
I loved attention and and was rewarded
for it relatively early if we're going
to go into sort of behavioural therapy
that's probably why when the bell rang I
came and expected my my treat but I also
had positive feedback over the years I
did it in in middle school in high
school and then in college and I got a
scholarship to do it in college and it
was just one of those things that I kept
coming back to and people kept seemingly
saying hey you're not bad at this and in
fact you you can be kind of good at it
and do you want to do it and if you do
maybe we'll pay you which was kind of
the first thing I ever the first
experience I ever had with that like hey
that sounds like a job but it's a job of
some doing something that actually like
which sounds a lot less like a job so
yeah I mean that's I I consider myself
incredibly fortunate every day to to get
to do something that I enjoy so much and
have people tell me they like it and
then other people give me paychecks for
it so is there something that you can
point to after this is concluded that
you would like to do directing acting
anything specific
well nothing specific I guess I would
like to do I would like to keep my
options open because I've been very
fortunate to be able to work with a lot
of interesting people in various
capacities whether it's producing or
acting or directing or or you know
podcasting there's been a lot of things
that I've done out there so hopefully
I'll get a chance to keep doing all of
them as long as I don't burn any bridges
or embarrass myself to to significantly
I think I'll be able to maintain a
presence in in you know in hopefully a
lot of places so I'm not going to say no
to any of them let last point to you is
there a particular actor actress writer
director someone that you wish that you
had met or that you had worked with oh
there's probably a thousand of them and
it's you know if you just look at at the
last few years whether it's Martin
Scorsese or
Wes Anderson or there's just so many
David O'Russell there's there's so many
people out there that are working at
such a high level and some of the people
I know and some I don't but I hope I get
a chance to work with with all of them
because I feel like we all we all play
up to the level of our competition and I
look forward to working with people who
inspire me and and scare me and and make
me work harder